[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily an
update now in the so-called doomsday
cult Duo case out of Idaho defendant
Chad Dabo now says he wants his coming
trout severed from wife Lori valadebell
the pair phase charges in the deaths of
Lori valo davao's two children J.J valo
and Tyler Ryan as well as Chad dabell's
first wife Tammy the couple was married
in 2019 just weeks after Tammy dabell
mysteriously died in her sleep and
followed dabel's youngest children went
missing in June 2020 the remains of JJ
and Tyler were recovered on Chad dabel's
property last week an Idaho judge ruled
cameras will not be allowed inside the
courtroom of the pairs January 2023
trial this week Chad dabell's team filed
in motion asking for his trial to be
severed from his wife and be pushed off
until next fall dabell's attorneys Ru
prosecutors have not handed over a
significant amount of evidence and that
there is quote no possible way okay to
complete the investigation and be
prepared for a death penalty trial in
January of 2023. they also say that
trying day Bell with his wife would
deprive him from his constitutional
right to present a complete defense
Lisa surprise surprise someone wants to
sever their case why do you think this
move was done so late in the game and
what could that signal for Chow's
defense
Lisa
oh I'm sorry I didn't know that was for
me
I believe that his attorney doesn't want
she had to be grouped in with the Alex
Cox killing Lori's husband and Lori's
brother who was involved who's no longer
with us and because of the three murders
that Chad has to already contend with
being his wife and the two children
where he's implicated it wouldn't make
sense for the attorney to want to have
that grouped in with him because of the
bias and the opportunity of not having a
fair trial yeah it makes sense avoid
some of the charges you don't have to
eat but also potentially point the
finger at your co-defense and then Terry
could this lead to a renewal for a
request to have cameras in the court for
one or both of the separate trials if
that does happen
well Brian let's hope that is exactly
what happens this is one of the biggest
cases in the country no doubt about it
people want to see Justice especially
for JJ and Tyler they were innocent
beautiful children and if that case is
severed then it could be moved to
another courtroom it could even go to
another venue and go before another
judge and if that happens it does make
sense to try to do a motion for cameras
in the courtroom and it could very well
be that the judge decides this is the
type of case that they need to have
these cameras so that the public can see
so that the criminal justice system can
really be viewed by everyone and you
know I do think it's interesting that
John Pryor Chad's attorney is saying he
needs more time and he's saying he's
needs that time because he's trying to
prepare for the defense he's had tons of
time to prepare for the defense he knew
this was a death penalty case so I do
find it interesting I definitely think
he's going to try to put this down the
road as long as he can and he will be
pointing the figure I am searched at
Lori and if he does that it makes a
strong argument to several let's see how
this case continues we have cameras I'm
not sure but thank you both and thank
you for joining us here on Law and crime
daily we'll see you next time as we
discuss Justice in America
[Music]